first of all Rose are you now in a
relationship with a woman whoo the
90-day fiance before the 90 days cast
might have been at home for the season
for tell-all but that did not stop
emotions from don't point your finger at
me it also didn't get in the way of
everybody I mean everybody letting Big
Ed know exactly how they feel no no
don't tell me to hold on it baby girl
can ask you a question
oh and shout-out to Darcy who looks
snatched in that gold dress prevents
body look and I think Yolanda finally
accepts the fact that Williams was a
scammer
I think Yolanda did Williams sound
British to you now that I am again you
sound like Osman hey my 90 day fans film
its Melissa here you know I had my
reservations about watching the teleport
teen style but I must admit I was both
shocked and satisfied let's go ahead and
get into the major highlights coming in
at number one Rose revealed that she
actually dated a woman after breaking it
off with big a take a look Rose are you
now in a relationship with a woman or no
no before so after you broke up with
Edie you started a relationship with the
woman yes okay
rumors of Rose dating a woman started
circulating maybe early spring no big
deal what I couldn't get over is the
fact that Rose was so upset with Edie
that she requested a translator to be
able to express her frustration that's
how pissed she was
you know they broke up after edge told
rose basically I can't give you a kid I
don't want to have kids with you take
STD test gave her some mouthwash and
actor to shave her legs now during the
tell-all and apologized but he didn't
apologize for asking her to do those
things he apologized for the way he acts
during the conversation Rose was visibly
emotional I mean my heart was going out
to her I just wanted to give her a hug
and then comes Tiffany Ed's daughter yes
Tiffany man in a parent's job she came
in and it was her first time having the
opportunity to speak to Rose and she
didn't hold back take a look did you
really love him because he really did
love you because he was willing to give
me up don't get a tone with me please
I'm just asking you a general question
you know tiffany has always had an issue
with rose and Ed's relationship mainly
because of the huge age difference
Rose is 24 Tiffany as daughter's 29 so
there's about a 30 year age gap in
between rows and Ed and Tiffany is just
not here for it back in April edie
opened up to ETS lauren zima about the
status of his relationship with his
daughter tiffany here's what he had to
say we're actually in a better place
than we were before
like even before this because now we now
where the very honest with with each
other which is even better so we're in a
great place
now speaking of relationship statuses
every an - announced that they are done
here's why they decided to call it quits
so he didn't follow a diet that this
sounds so weird to me
so he it does he didn't get so a diet
and is that the reason that we're here
is that was the reason no it was the
reason Avery to judge him for a small
diet okay that's really penny and diet
if he was out and you score tea with
another woman that would be different
but a diet come on Avery you been around
you've had many boyfriends do you have
two daughters
a diet seriously that's not normal
first of all Lisa and Ed's commentary
during the tunnel was one of my favorite
parts but every breaking up with ash
it's bigger than the diet I get it you
know I feel like the diet is the straw
that just broke the camel's back
every has said from the beginning she's
always had this gut instinct that she
couldn't trust ash and that's a lesson
for all of us listening follow your gut
she's revealed bad this has been an
issue in their relationship from the
start so I feel like if you would lie
about a little diet what else would you
lie about if I'm thinking about spending
the rest of my life with you I want to
trust the words that come out of your
mouth and if you aren't being honest
about something as simple as a diet what
else are you not being honest about I
felt like every was over the
relationship from that moment that huge
argument they had after Ash's seminar
yeah remember that do you want to come
talk to me yeah I'm just thinking house
fear I pushed that right now yeah in
that moment I knew every was done
despite their relationship status the
two still have a lot of respect for each
other and may ash actually took up for
Avery on social media after her
ex-husband made some serious claims
against her claiming that she was an
unfit mother Ashe posted a photo of
Avery and her daughter silver saying in
part quote I don't know the ex-husband
but I know Avery and I've seen her care
love support and fight for her kids
that's right ash you stand up for Avery
finally a moment from the TEL on that
left us all confused I'm sorry but I
just saw a side of it makes me feel like
he's an untrustworthy person in fairness
in fairness I'm not willing to continue
talking while she's here well who's here
Oh Avery
why because I have an issue where the
side I prefer not to speak savory look
tom was so uninterested in talking about
the problem between him and avery that
he ended the video call so if this
wasn't quarantine staff that's
equivalent to him walking off the stage
now when it comes to actually what went
down between Tom and Avery we got a
glimpse in a preview for part two of the
tell-all take a look
Avery okay everybody's confused right
now what happened I was in a
relationship he sends me a text message
dad Oh Stephanie did oh I mean really
Tom really in that moment my heart
dropped for Darcy I'm sorry Tom dating
anybody on the show is off-limits
it's off-limits you can't do it it's
just not right
now when it comes to what actually went
down between Tom and Avery we're gonna
have to wait to see but in the meantime
let's take a look at the explosive part
two of the tell-all airing Monday on TLC
so Lana's still on those dating sites
yes this was a job for her she gets paid
David defends his relationship with Lana
and yes we finally get to hear from us
men and baby girl Lisa love you treated
him like a little coat yeah explosives
might be an understatement all right my
90 day fans fam make sure you stick with
ET for more updates from our favorite
guilty pleasure see you next time
[Music]